[Music]
my first flight was when I was 18 years old
the first time I flew was very beautiful
because I
felt joy, sadness and at the same time a
little fear
[Music]
the pole was only 15 meters long but
I felt that those 15 meters were like
40 of 50 meters
at the moment of going up I felt as if
my stomach had a bar of ice
because it was very cold
[Music] being
able to climb was something wonderful
because at that moment I felt like I
wanted to fly
[Music]
I imagined myself as a bird  flying
I was the first woman to fly in
Mexico
[Music]
before, women couldn't
participate
in other towns they don't let us play
the flying stick or do the
ceremony because they say that this could
have great consequences in an
accident  but this already the woman already
participated in the ceremonies of the
ancestors so I feel that it
is only like a myth
when I decide to be a flyer to be an
integral part of this dance the
ugliest obstacles are  n of the family itself because of the
machismo that because the woman and I
could not do it because the woman who looked
bad
but little by little they get
used to it because one continues to be
and doing so they
end up accepting that decision
the last  ritual in the dance like this is to
ask for rain before the
ancestors had a good harvest it
is a ritual in the sun because from the
moment one goes to the forest to cut the
stick an exchange is made with bad
nature to take away a son who
becomes  in part of our dance
[Music]
the dance originates from Mesoamerica
we do not know from what year it started but the
dance is pre-Hispanic because they worshiped
the gods
[Music
] today we do it to
a saint in this case it does not have spoons
to the patron saint of san francisco
[Music]
jacinta the flyer the one
who flies on the flying stick the famous ribbon the flyer the one who flies
the
flying stick
is the 15 laps each belt  to so famous
blowing up the truth of the whole world
the film attracts everyone
the famous flying stick response to the
town first place
[Music]
I have vertigo when I go up to a
34-story house on the roof and I look out
but when I go up  no value
there I feel safer and I have no news
that moment becomes magical
[Music]
when I start to climb I only
concentrate on going up step by
step step by step
then it is totally
100% concentrated in the dance  in that vital at this
moment
[Music]
at the moment of opening my arms is something
wonderful and very fantastic because at
that moment I know how I can fly just
like once
I no longer feel like a little bird in a
cage they are closed and what is that  I'm
free
[Music]
the time to fly is something spectacular
and dangerous one's life depends on nothing
more than a rope from a loop I know I'm going
to go up but more I don't know if I'm going to go
down
[Music
] currently my  My family has changed their
minds
now they consider me an artist
[Applause]
I'm from a family of flyers and I feel
very proud to be a woman and above all
a flying woman and a dance that gives
more before was represented by men
[Music]
you